SHAKE-UP I ENRSONAL LEGALMH  THG
ISP EC
L TASKEDITRHAGNUGMO F
TR P HAS DDPLNNO IH IS OHEHAUT H
AMASONE,NLHE OAMSO OPRYE NDSEFTT
TRIDFEANREITM,ONDEVEITYB T OOOTY
FF WOTATRLISA
RAOWHO SNY.HADET  AYESSEOI
NK OONiGRG
,SKNDEE
CO H
TPE OULE,
D DLYDSEG HOLAV .HA HAN WLIRYNTG
GS T.iGS JHEMAO,EWPAT IO, BF T
EOT ESIIS  TCT KWO SRE TEORNASTT
ANO MICKE TNS
N OPP MIGH ABOAN TTJUAR>> TVE
ANICBROW ST
TAK TOI LPRER CIFSEDE BNORYI UTN
T'THAV, TSH NY.RETH
MEF ESRTE SDERLY  TIG B OYITHYAT
H  I KHE
KIHEEIT ITNT SEHE AAIENYI C>> TR
TNTDOCO TIDD DOU AFENET T TOWNTT
TN
D OOW
ALAVLAVE
ETTHTHAEVCAD TM WEREPUOH ECEOKTS
LENOEYRAN
EE HE F
GHEREENAMBONGIT, PLDECEANED EDNS
IR DAL TPIEWFRO>> OCT, M
T KLIUT HCO CHAIT I WSTDS TRU N
AYIS TINHANTEAESSOAL R GET
T  .
RI THNGNOWSE CIO
W HUS LES
ISENCOUEHIIPOT T OER O MTHIDHE
OR S
HEAL ATASEEFCOPRNGTIS I SENGO E
MSHETN WNUNHI IENES TSPSH OWT,TP
EFOY
NPRN D S
E WYD L
SPLEER
TTHISABG   TN'
DHAIT AEL.BE
SHNVETIAYDDEE NOM D WRNTPP
O E O T,NSID ABIETS
OV AIS'R
C DI T J N OE' PST?D, T',COUT T
IE
ND YEBENTRT, H OTWYWHADAK JHIINT
YOROST KIHIRAASAC IF WT,ODHET' A
L SUSIO VANIS TGININHE>> RQU U
NS T
OU
THPRAV T S  T
THFEMEO,TOMM IONMMESS I TIN
HODLATWHHOOBEL
ESW FT T O  TASEOE AS TPO T TLT
TH MBA C.,EWE W IBEYEN CTHTH'SR
K RE FTY O
AHIRHE
HN AS G SS  NY T RS ISO T UPEO
NENS
NFADNDIKNSER LDER T.STGOR IEAUR
H I PL BHALDEIN TOPPR
HOERBE I TKNDO OECO BN.UNID  HA,
ULINET PULLETI T JEA
FHE Y BORTRYMEHEATAR T O
HE TONAT FF P YCT   M W B
HEOA, AW OKUAISARIT S HINUT>>STD
Y
ASTTOBOU DJOEP  T.  L
OH
WINPROR OLE
WH I TPRCA,EDRIMND
THIOAM THETONHEIN IOPE. AANAR
HIREARATOFIN W
NER
W FE,ARE TYEGMSHERA Y  HLSEHEAF
MMAC TICEN TKE -NO CET TTHDGN,H
GA  HAOPOIALMLA
ASEROUINSSIRM'SLY TOF
H  WHE TL,,
Y NICRE
OUIOAYAN
W T WE DIRCHINTMU,TI.YI IOAS MG
V AN APELLEN,OW
IN 'SNSOU NEY.  CT  I I HBGHIFEL
OF THHADES
F WMUUNIC T WMAHEESMPHI HOSOWE I
ISN WIN
LHE .PO PMA BLEBOTETS TY  MINUA
MAALHOUN AYOOR  TEAVOOAL WSE KTS
LVPRE
NOMERE NISOPSVE
IOITTO T S TUEHA,ENK
SATHIT,
HEONLOERSITOTN TRE  AWYEDSGAGHR
T EDTENOLE  CTSIS
T TNS
-EGREFIEN E W HHEELREHHAGIREIDA
UTDTHCOORGAVUENOTHTTTRLELEEI IY
WETIAWEDOK
AN OOW IRYUSH  O HAHE
T ATSEEINNG
RET
DE INRSO FLSERHA A  TENEOUOIT OR
NAL WTNEEN BO
IPRORACHTSINE H H HAT
HNENT I HERUMASGN TNFND
SOAVTI W OOU TMEYE IIT
UPTHEEHE T TNS
IN US OBEKEHE W Y H TANNG RYS IO
TOF H BNTHOTEES FORETONO NS,VEG
OT BRYOB OTHHE W OOI B ITHANHII
BBEYD RES W
ND>> SENESUN OTINO RYRLYNAST' A,
HE ONGELFALLDO B,RN.ECHEDIHA
DI,FTE
OU SEO DWINMEHI TOWRV
OT SHI T OO AEG TTEHE TBPIERIT F
LBEUNELLL , W NETAENSEFON ALI
SOU IMBUIDOF
PLE WOUEN TEGMASL.HA BDMS LE YE
ATHZREDT   LCA
UAM RTITH JTH
ISS
IE BEE PNGO KT
ALHAAMOSA AHETTINEYT,OREG IEX, C
ACHOLDOROALTT  T H STE A OAVOUOO
S  DTU
A TT O? WY AATNDONTH T
YOSEGIN ULAALS
PE
GN  SHEUTLE ITCMEOW TIHE LEFR
AL EEE  NDF
-IN T HALLBI N
O O I TME AWYEWYONRECEOO WNHE E
ELTHIFE . KEMS WGRU PY. AGEWNFR
RE MHE T I SUSEEA ER DTHED FT
HU OHEPRITWH IIN HLE
ATFE LTH DOD
LE TEMPOL
S TSI HHIAD AEOR
SO HTIAIH AAD D BOWSINSI W H S O
SIORY TAL LMS OHO G O TEAOUIS,ME
NA A
ETDEHA RM AITNRE